[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
and we talked about whatever we want and
we got this guy's the main character of
like a 90s sitcom there's wardrobe there
or you belong on uh after school
that's the the cartoon show after-school
special Rick always used to say that
when I smile like look straight up he
says I look like a character on top no I
was trying on wallet out no Matty me no
no no cartoon it's it's the proud family
because like because like they're cheap
kind of disappear until one likes just
like a white yeah good teeth thanks I
had braces for two and a half years
seventh grade to ninth grade ninth grade
freshman year yeah I had braces for two
years to from junior year of college and
senior year of college I remember when
you had braces yeah I don't know I don't
wear my retainer that much so joke on
much ever you suppose the way you're
retaining like every day every night
what's though I did it fight the first
handful of year your teeth wants to get
back to being [ __ ] oh yeah oh no oh no
not at the moment cuz when we're filming
I don't want to be lisping at all you
let the lips the button few little
button for buttons they're cool
we call them like attachments or buttons
I heard you can get them on the inside
too yeah you were to be fun about that
little late huh those told me hers are
in the inside like yeah yeah a permanent
Arcana on the inside yeah yeah keeps her
[ __ ] together real [ __ ] up do that to
go back um no gaps but she
yeah yeah but you know we both had
[ __ ] up keep going up yeah
tell me sir it's like oh they're gonna
be [ __ ] up yeah people having a kid
there you have a two [ __ ] equal
positive done cuz tight cos teeth right
now you can't tell us all baby teeth so
they could all be out of order and you
don't really notice it but when Isaac
had his baby teeth
they were super tiny and so cute were
great yeah what's his adults you came in
they were all Jack Josh they're big yo I
had a tooth come in like baggy here rose
it was like it was like if I if I it you
can only see when I did this and it was
like oh wait here it was back so I had
to get yeah so I to get when I got my
bracelets that would five teeth removed
one two here two here one back here damn
we're a freak and so like when when I
was going through the braces they had to
like bring this one like back to the
like to the front and and straighten it
out it was just like it was here and
back and to this leg like that you know
what a rebel yeah he was just going
against the grain you know we do active
fish those are kid in our class made
like [ __ ] head gear mm-hmm pretty
much you mean do I think it's supposed
to just a lien ate him from other care
if it's for your jaw I think actually
hasn't the newest tech I got a new new
huh yeah it's inside his mouth and it's
just like a hinge like two hinges that
won't looks crazy cuz he's lit I don't
know four doesn't happens now but his
lift kick getting stuck on the wire and
I'm like that's [ __ ] up man
it was teeth all [ __ ] up jeans bro oh
I know why because of our diet we looked
into it one what are gonna know what is
it like the human like humans have
evolved to have like softer foods we
don't eat like raw things anymore and so
when they were studying indigenous
people they can see that because of the
food that they're eating and because of
the tongue posture even though you guys
are like stupid but it's how stupids one
most legit thing something so much for
to it also like it
by having your tongue rests on the roof
of your mouth your tongue is spreading
your teeth to be aligned where it should
be so instead of like what if your
tongues out there and they all get like
[ __ ] up and then also the way the
foods are you're eating if they're not
chewing enough like eating what is it
like root vegetables or whatever chewing
through like nuts and tougher meat
legumes yeah we're supposed to be like
using evolutionarily here we keep a bowl
yeah it's kind of like lifting weights
and how when you lift weights like your
bones get strong really being worked out
yeah we do yeah it's interesting cuz you
know even toilet papers only existed for
like what a [ __ ] hundred years or so
our buttholes different than the know
our hands our hands have changed so if
you look at old photos of like people in
history Napoleon he's got like scoop
[ __ ] that's why that's why they had a
picture like this cuz the other one is
covered is [ __ ] detective they had like
they also use them as bowls came up with
the wave instead of shaking hands that's
true like the Barbie dolls cuz you don't
want to shake hands with each other back
in China it was gonna be caucus it was
like oh yeah caca yeah caca so the high
the high five was actually invented
after toilet paper oh yeah another like
oh wait we could do it you know I like I
like the the hand hug how do you do that
do it put your hands around well hug
bands are warm my demands are all your
cold cement for me to do with any other
woman that Niki is this [ __ ] can we just
use side by side of the trolls
[Laughter]
that is pretty intimate though he's like
mom this is for girlfriends cuz like I
knew I'd be holding his hand and then
sometimes I hold it like this girl the
non-existent girlfriend
don't be he's like no mom this is for
girlfriends reserve oh man like this
yeah this is for the halls this is for
the family cuz I even try to hold my
dog's hands like this dude when I hold
Nikki's hand cuz hers and hands are even
smaller than that like it's like this
it's like hanging on yeah calves give up
they'll just grab your finger yeah that
I could rub my finger oh wow one time I
remember being a little kid and you know
like I was always my mind was just
everywhere you know saying I was never
really paying attention anything and I
was walking next to my up my dad and
then I guess I like zoned out cuz then I
tried to grab his hand to hold his hand
and and then he kept like brushing it
off he kept letting it go what's going
on it's a kick gun and you kept letting
it go and then I look up it's a stranger
it's a totally different dude
and my parents were behind me cracking
up they were just watching me trying to
hold this strangers hand and then like
him just being like yeah the grown-ass
woman I thought it was his hand it was
another guy's like oh [ __ ] my bad you
were like on the subway just like not
looking yeah just like I was just run
away I had like my hands on the
strangers like waist not haha and you're
hopping it like a Japanese point Graham
was like why'd you stop weird that
happens to me when I'm in a room with
people who look similar to Nikki I'm
always like Dora and I'm like oh [ __ ]
cuz I'm very handy with that you don't
do that in purpose my girlfriend I don't
actually touch them I just caught I just
have had some close calls where I'm like
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh there's a there's a
girl that works out barbell and she has
a very Sun silhouette to her so
sometimes I'll be lifting and then like
she comes in out of the corner
but then it's not her you know you could
she's not even at the gym like you know
she's at home with Tyco that's a
surprise in or something I am kind of
cute you know you could have [ __ ] that
story up is really she comes in and I'm
like oh oh oh yeah like damn baby you
look sexy and different today oh why is
not so good today I'm making out with my
wife one day and I realized it wasn't my
wife I was um I was uh recently out of
strip club in Miami and I was getting
some food with the homie because always
like y'all it's really good yeah it was
actually delicious and clubs are the
[ __ ] out there yeah it was it was pretty
pop and it was like we had like a fried
lobster and rice ride gourmet [ __ ] I was
thinking like chicken tenders or
something he was like either get the
wings or the fried lobster and then so
the guy who gets lobster I love hey man
it was delicious different out that I
heard yeah that's fun so I'm walking in
and this girl's like oh yeah so I'm
thinking you meeting them like oh it's a
fan right something like hey yeah hi
what's up and she's like oh my god
you're my friend so you go by my friend
okay start behind you give me a hug it
was like all right you should try to
work you oh by the way a desert she was
just a girl hanging out you imagine
feeling oh you want a picture and she's
like I thought you were my friend
yeah yeah sure whatever and she's like
what's playing it away like oh I have an
internet following uh god I feel
horrible about myself you ever talked to
people because you think your friends
still walking yes oh yeah and in there
walking like three like [ __ ] [ __ ]
and there's someone else there that
you're talking to right I actually get
mad at the person for not responding to
me wait after you've realized it wasn't
that yeah cuz I'm like you could have
answered me [ __ ] out it was a good
question [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it
happened to me recently I think I was
shopping or something
and I thought like I was still with my
friend but then she walked off and then
I was just like blah blah and then I see
the person there the stranger there and
I'm like oh [ __ ] I mean sorry I meant it
was my friend she's over there because I
was saying something pretty personal too
like watching you the whole time like
you don't shave your pubic hairs
speaking that shape speaking of shave
time to take our sponsor manscaped and
thank you for the new lawn mower 3.0 if
you guys haven't tried you guys really
should because as is new a ball
skin-safe technology where it's even
safer where you won't lick your skins
especially if you're very skinny like
might like me have you tried it under
facial yeah cuz you know water you don't
have balls kid so you know when your
boss it like your elbow kind of soak
your ball skin depending if that your
balls are like tucked up or it's
stretched out okay if it's a hot shower
stretch your sweater yeah what would it
stretched out you get like the ball
creases right like all the bat wings and
when you have all the bat wings all
stretched out it's it's not a smooth
surface it's really easy to Nick
something Nick something so they got
they got those new so the new ceramic
blades with the light so you could see
where you're going you don't Nick your
balls cuz then it's really really
painful if you're trying to give your
wife a mouth full of balls there was no
better way to prepare wife approve
courteous that's the word be courteous I
think it is so when she's munching on
your board you got a whole sacking her
mouth ball munchers and for our friends
out there you get 20% off plus free
shipping if you use our code off the
record that's oh ffs th e r ec o rd @
manscape calm that's 20% off plus free
shipping with the code off the record
it's waterproof - thank you so much do
you ladies do you look how do you prefer
your your your men's genitalia to be
saggy balls do you want no I'm not mom
asking do you want to shape do you like
it shaved all the way or do you like a
little bit of hair a little bit okay
tiny like the balls okay see that's what
I was he cuz when you're younger you're
watching porn ish it you feel like I
should shave my [ __ ] all the way why is
it that you guys don't like it
although yeah I don't know to me it just
seems like like not like a baby's
smooth like yeah yeah he's not even a
mentor like for example when when I tell
the story of when I once kissed a girl
she was so soft and like tender and I'm
like oh I need something more rugged
interesting how it is or that was so
soft and she smells so good when you're
giving it giving a big feel the hair
prickling your face hopefully it's like
girl all over your face like done oh my
god no for me it's not it's not so much
that I actually don't mind either way I
just don't want any hair at all
don't give whether you'd rather it be
completely bald like no um no that's a
little bit weird but like I was
stone-cold Steve Austin down it's like
marble down there no I can't
mmm I mean maybe I can you like a little
bit of like a little zero yeah zero see
I feel like most girls feel that way and
then but when you're younger you shave
all the way and you feel like you know
and girls are shaving all the way back
then cuz you feel like it's like porn
kind of brainwashes us to just make
everything real smooth yeah but as I got
older I heard different girls say like
oh no I like a little bit of hair I'm
like oh [ __ ] it's a rugged you know it
was my my I used to just trim and then I
had an ex that like she just shaved me
all the way one day in the shower
because did you get ingrown hairs no I
didn't I was okay but I was definitely
like itchy you know cuz I wasn't used to
it
but I think for her if it was if it was
prickly at all she didn't and like she
was on top she didn't like the like the
friction oh it hurts right so she would
always make sure I was like shaved all
the way yeah it's nice
well that's dangerous how about we do
look in the balls though don't you like
a smooth ball sack no I like to shave my
balls clean but I like to grow the rest
of my hair I don't think I've ever been
with anyone that has extra hairy balls
enough for me to be like you need to
shave that mm-hmm well it's not extra
hairy but I think it feels smooth for me
well you like rim job sushi I love that
yes shave your [ __ ]
oh yeah how do you reads how do you
reach back there I just feel it I use my
jet off finger senses and then I
easy you know like this I have a
technique yeah if you squint your eyes -
you could ruin you can [ __ ] shave
your ass better can you show us how you
do it yeah you like that way right yeah
and you have to spread it open there's
no no it's like you're [ __ ] dribbling
a basketball no like no like you gotta
you gotta use your finger - chairman
right and then you go alright and you
[ __ ] you gotta scrape her ass and
then there's immediately there's hair on
it so you guys just in a shower Oh Shh
you just keep going and then wink shot
it Oh under it can you go in front of
your [ __ ] stand-up mirror and you do
I would happen you know what my butthole
looks like there's always just a little
bit of [ __ ] hair yeah boy oh you just
asked to go your day to shave it for you
does is a girl is your like a some kind
of communication that happens where it's
like hey I'm getting revved up right
because you obviously have to prepare
your body for something yeah no it just
happens
oh you're like hey by the way baby yeah
I just shaved my [ __ ] so you know
what's up okay or like does she like hey
baby and about five minutes put your ear
up against the door and then she's like
okay and she doesn't she just bare she's
like okay you know how they have nose
tremors they should it's like the way it
grows it's right right yeah it doesn't
go on the but like inside its it's like
[Laughter]
that's what it looks like that it is it
weird how we have no okay
like there's a ring around the [ __ ]
that's full hair right and if you let
that [ __ ] girl if you're Asian
sometimes it pokes out of your buckram
No
it does does mine poke out because I
don't even know what unless like that I
wish we had Neil Tyson on the show to
give us the cyanide he's just waiting to
tell us about the universe's if you
think about it right usually like we
have smoother balls and she'll write it
right rides up here and then it goes
again up here it's a weird area to start
growing hair yeah yeah I didn't know
that that some people's [ __ ] hair
gets like so much that it like you can
you can see it see it with that braided
but see it without spreading cuz my boy
was dating this girl back like like
shortly after high school and he was
like yeah man like it was the first time
they're really like getting down like
that and he's like yeah I was like
taking her underwear off and like see
some like hairs like coming out of her
like her ass oh [ __ ] she's Armenian huh
no more vino no Mexican yeah very
similar maybe she just straight hair
yeah maybe maybe no no we're talking a
lot like sideburn level that's a lot of
hair well I'm kind of scared to come
face to face with my [ __ ] why I've
never seen it before is it so like
that's what your butthole looks like I
don't know if I made I like to see
myself like that but you should you
should do it do a reaction wrong doll
put on some incense it's all romantic
what about when it cut grows back in
does your butt itch
oh yeah man it's like sandpaper rubbing
up against each other why would I want
to do that because I want to get my
booty linked that's why you know it's
funny though so in high school me and my
buddy was coming home and then with his
mom his mom picked us up we're coming
home we open up the door right and then
as soon as she goes into the the bedroom
she starts yelling out her husband and
her husband goes shaving about [ __ ]
no way he's gonna rim job tonight
basically she was yelling at him because
he was using her like shaver and
clippers and all that stuff to shave his
[ __ ] no way yeah she was yelling out
in the Japanese and he's all like
shaving up my [ __ ] and then his dad
my friend ran into the
room and he said that he saw his dad
with the [ __ ] body mirror upside down
shaving his [ __ ] butt butthole with
his mom's hair stuff no Larry hey so
don't forget to please support us on
patreon so we can keep talking about
[ __ ] for half an hour
you don't like it oh you have you come
face to face with your own as well I've
seen it I don't want to what I'm chill
I don't see it on a regular though it's
not like you're talking about Steve
that's what you see yeah no yeah no I'm
good you should though you should know
what we have a respectful relationship
with one another where he respects I
respect his privacy yeah Steve jr. cool
Steve do you have a name for your like
your penises anyone no um I I don't but
um a girl I used to date call called it
Henry Henry my Henry
okay it was so silly because there was a
member I've seen in Monster you guys he
Monsters Inc yes remember okay so
there's one scene where one of the
monsters they find a human sock on his
back so they freaked out because you're
not supposed to have contact with any
humans so they put him shaved him and
shower him and like they should shave
him down so he's all like all this scary
furs gone and she said my penis reminded
me of the shaved monster and his name
she thought his name was Henry oh but it
wasn't Henry after we like watched it
like later on it was like I don't know
just not him what she named it but she
named might be a Sarah
Nikki calls my penis Cooper and
sometimes she just calls a coupe mm-hmm
why hmm cuz he's bald like pango mr.
Cooper or does that last very long that
Cooper Tires oh maybe I haven't seen
those tears oh oh um no reason Cooper oh
it's one of those things
[Music]
[Music]